There are probably few experiences you could
have that would confuse your brain more than
almost dying.
Hey friends, Laci Green here for DNews.
"Near death experiences" have been described
by people across the world who came--or thought
they were coming--within an inch of their
life.
What's totally crazy is that no matter who
you are, where you come from---everyone describes
it very similarly.
It starts with a warmth spreading throughout
their body, absolute serenity and calm, some
might even call it nirvana.
Then comes a bright light and a feeling of
being detached from the body, as if you were
floating.
The number of people who have a near death
experiences is on the rise, thanks to technologies
that can save people at the last moment.
Naturally, there's a burning question:
WHAT DOES IT ALL MEAN!??
This is a complicated and emotionally charged
question.
For some, the near death experience is proof
of the afterlife.
For others, it's a fascinating neurological
question.
Let's take a look at this phenomenon through
a scientific lens.
One of the most highly regarded studies on
NDEs comes from the University of Kentucky.
They found that some Near Death Experiences
may actually be something called REM intrusion.
During REM intrusion, the mind awakes before
the body, which can trigger hallucinations.
It's sort of like dreaming - while you're
awake, kind of.
I covered this phenomenon in my video about
sleep paralysis, so if you're interested you
should definitely check that out cause it's
freaky stuff.
Because REM intrusion happens in the brainstem,
it's possible for this to occur even when
higher functioning parts of the brain have
gone dead.
Building on this research, trauma to the brain
can result in a sensory mix-up.
As your brain struggles to stay alive, all
of that chaos results in an information overload
in the visual cortex.
This is known to produce visions of a bright
light or a dark tunnel.
The brain also releases a flood of happy endorphins
which put you in a profound state of peace
and calm.
And because your brain is responsible for
orienting your body relative to everything
around you, trauma and oxygen deprivation
can cause a sort of out of body experience.
This has been observed in lots of people who
aren't having a near death experience as well.
Lastly, a new study has been published by
the Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences on NDEs.
The study was done on rats and found that
after cardiac arrest, there is a crazy spike
in neural activity.
The lead author says that "if anything, the
brain is much more active during the dying
process than even the waking state".
Essentially, the neurons go into overdrive
as death sets in, causing the brain to go
haywire in a predictable way - cue warmth,
bright light, floating, etc.
We perceive this experience with profound
intensity as our brain takes a last hurrah
before death.
I can't decide if this is beautiful or terrifying
or depressing or what.
Let me know your thoughts about near death
experiences down below or on our facebook
page and I'll see you next time here on DNews!